hey guys so I am at Microsoft right now
and they just announced something so
incredible that's basically gonna change
the way that we search the internet now
search has been the same for like the
past 20 plus years for basically as long
as I can remember which is actually
quite a long time I know I don't want to
talk about it I have been obsessed with
AI not only AI technology but AI photos
AI video I'm sure everyone has heard
about chat gbt of course people using it
to write research papers and whatever
else I've actually been using chat gbt
to write little stories that go along
with AI images that I created so I made
this little AI Instagram account
unfortunately AI Justine was was taken
ironically I don't know I'm very sad
about it so it's iJustine AI so I will
go in I'll use mid-journey to make the
images and then chat gbt to actually
write the text but the thing that upsets
me about chat gbt and I think there's a
big misconception with chat gbt is
everything that it says is true it is
the truth and that's I think gonna be
something that is a bigger conversation
so basically what it's doing is it's
giving you a conversational feel but a
lot of the data that is in there is from
like 2021 so it's not updated so what
Bing and Microsoft has been doing is
really really game changing because it's
kind of taking that conversational model
and putting it into search like right
alongside of it they also have it built
directly into the edge browser so right
up here you'll see when you click that
like this just opens right up like you
can chat you can compose and it also
gives you some insights but I want to
give you guys a little demo of how this
works and how game changing this is for
search for finding information and
basically just saving us a ton of time
so I recently have been getting into
snowboarding haven't snowboarded no
nothing so I'm gonna use this to teach
me everything I need to know about
snowboarding and maybe even plan a trip
what do I need to know about
snowboarding you'll see here
over on this right hand section this is
where it's populating all of the search
results into kind of like bite size
researched information so it's giving
you a more conversational look at like
what this content is and I love these
little annotations right here because
this will let you go and actually find
the resources where they're getting this
information so you can continue to you
know do your own research which is
something that I feel like everyone
should do but with chat gbt you're not
getting any resources you're not getting
any links and a lot of times I have had
it write me scripts and then I went and
fact checked and like half the things
that this is saying like where are you
getting this information so with this it
shows you exactly where you're able to
get the information and up here you can
like or dislike and that will trigger to
Microsoft and Bing like this was either
factual or it wasn't so definitely use
that if it is helpful so we're in here
we've got all the information and on the
left like that's what a traditional sir
looks like but will link like this we go
into the chat this pulls that entire
little conversational chat that was on
the right hand side and we can continue
to break this search down into smaller
kind of bite-sized chunks of things so
this entire thing is all kind of paired
together so let's see where should I go
to snowboard as a beginner also I
spelled beginner wrongs so thankfully it
understands typos now this is pulling
all of these search results from all
over the web the annotations are still
there so you can click in this will pop
open a link to where it's getting that
information from so you can continue to
read the full articles so now that I've
learned everything that I need to know
about snowboarding uh I gotta go on a
trip where where's the best place to go
for beginners you can see I didn't say
snowboarding it's just gonna know
because that's what we're talking about
so it's now populated all the places to
go let's have this write me an email to
my friends and tell them we are going
here on a trip sure I can write you an
email to your friends to come on the
trip here's a possible email you can
the subject snowboard weekend trip so
the trip apparently is going to be
February 17th uh to the 19th we're going
to be going to like Tahoe it has amazing
snow stunning views this is too long
this is everywhere to make it shorter
because like I can't even read this
whole email it's way too long if I can't
read it my friends aren't going to read
it oh my God it's even giving me cost
the trip is gonna cost 500 per person
they need to let me know by February
13th if they can go now let's hop over
to the Bing integration with Edge and
check this out I would like to compare
the different types of
Jitsu practiced
currently we're going to have it be
casual generate this is great yeah well
look at this it's just populating it
right here why I like this is because
you can choose the typo formats you can
have it be a paragraph email you can do
a blog post or an ideas so let's make
this into a blog post so you see this
gives you a title Jiu Jitsu 101 a
comparison of different styles so this
gives you a completely different rewrite
of that text that you just saw one of
the things that I liked with chat gbt
when I was kind of writing my little
stories is sometimes I didn't like the
stories that it came up with so I would
do just a complete refresh so you can
regenerate an entire draft to get a
different version of that so one other
example that I thought was so cool is
they showed how to like plan like a meal
plan for the week I'm gonna say plan me
two days of meals of high protein day
one I'm gonna be having breakfast uh
spinach and egg Pizza snacks freaky okay
this is cool okay let's go into the chat
now what's cool is I can have this write
me things like you can have it write you
poems so for example for like one of my
AI images I would have it write me a
story about a little pig that lives in a
big world who is afraid of pants makes
no sense at all but it takes that prompt
and is going to write me a story it's
called the little pig who was afraid of
pants there once was a little pig who
lives in a big world he had a loving
family a Cozy home and many friends but
he had one big problem he was afraid of
pants this is definitely going to be the
story for today's Instagram AI so one of
the things that I really like is
comparing products because obviously I
do a ton of tech reviews and then for
you guys as a consumer this is so
helpful so I'm gonna search to compare
the best cameras of 2023 in a table so
as you can see this is all populating
here we've got the camera sensor
resolution viewfinder price Like This is
Gonna Save people so much time like I
can't even believe that the future is
here and we are future searching now
this was so much fun to get a chance to
check out like I love AI in the future
of what this means for us like if this
can make us take everyday mundane
activities and make them way more easier
like we can save so much time this is
going to be available to everyone in a
few of coming weeks but you can now sign
up if you'd like to get on the wait list
if you guys haven't already be sure to
like comment and subscribe to my YouTube
channel and comment below I would love
to hear what you guys think of this and
what do you think of AI in general let
me know in the comments below and I'll
see you guys in the next video bye
[Music]